bestseller-autor ein titel der
unerreichbar scheint und genau deswegen
so sehr reizt in sieben tagen allein ein
hochqualitatives buch schreiben das
klappt niemals was wäre aber wohl wenn
ich mit der community gemeinsam ein buch
schreibe in dem die besten
kurzgeschichten in den
unterschiedlichsten stilen zu finden
sind und wer ist so schaffen dass nicht
nur ich an bestseller-autoren titel
erhalte sondern alle aus der community
die es ins buch geschafft haben
so garantieren wir die besten
kurzgeschichten aus tausenden von köpfen
und machen möglicherweise ganz normale
leute auf einen schlag zum bestseller
autoren aber erstmal zum anfang ich habe
vor ca zwei monaten angefangen dieses
projekt zu planen endlich kann ich euch
davon erzählen es ist nämlich wirklich
eine menge passiert ich wollte die ganze
zeit schon ein buch schreiben es gab
aber zwei probleme zum einen haben meine
ideen einfach immer nur gereicht um ein
paar seiten zu füllen und kein ganzes
buch und auf der anderen seite hatte ich
das problem dass sich selber beim lesen
nicht durch ein ganzes buch
durchgekommen bin mit 100 oder 200
seiten ich habe immer nur drei seiten
gelesen das buch für ein paar tage weg
gelegt und dann nach ein paar tagen
weiter gelesen hatte aber natürlich
schon wieder komplett vergessen was ich
vor ein paar tagen gelesen hatte
also kann mir diese power idee einen
kurzgeschichten buch mit euch zusammen
ach ja und direkt mal vorweg um den
internetservice voller breitseite in die
analoge welt zu bekommen der top
kommentar unter diesem video wird der
titel des buches werden also lasst euch
was einfallen up bietet die sachen die
euch gefallen
ich werde auch in den kommentaren
unterwegs sein und meine favorite
raussuchen natürlich könnt ihr jetzt
nicht schreiben was irgendwie gegen agbs
verstößt womit wir dann das buch nicht
mehr auf irgend welchen webseiten
vertreiben könnten also probiert das in
dem rahmen zu halten
der ok ist aber ihr habt freiwald und
könnte sachen abholen okay die
theoretisch ist also geklärt wie wir das
buch geschrieben bekommen ich schreiben
teil ihr schreiben teil und verschiedene
youtuber schreiben auch ein teil dazu
aber mehr im zweiten teil von diesem
projekt also im zweiten video
ich habe also angefangen zu schauen wie
ich ein buch drucken wie ich das
veröffentliche wie ich das sein leben
bekomme
wer macht das verleger hat mich also mit
verlagen zusammen gesetzt und geschaut
was es die mir so anbieten können was
die für mich für jobs übernehmen und wie
viel das ganze nicht an kostet und wie
viel wir daran verdienen und so weiter
das hat direkt einen riesen haufen
scheiße offenbart denn dieses ganze
system von büchern ist gefühlt
infiltriert von alteingesessenen firmen
von alteingesessenen leuten die macht
haben und von ganz ganz komischen
geldverteilung und es wurde angeboten
dass wir für unser buch oder an unserem
zwischen einem euro und einem euro 15
pro verkauftem buch mitverdienen ihr
könnt euch schon vorstellen dass wenn
jetzt 20 leute ins buch schaffen wir da
als einzelne wahrscheinlich nicht so
super viel dran verdienen würden das hat
mich als erstes schon mal komplett vom
hocker gehauen und dann habe ich gedacht
ich nehme das ganze selber in die hand
also weil es ja ziel sein sollte
bestseller autor zu werden musste ich
irgendwie trotzdem weg finden in den
handel reinzukommen damit einfach unsere
daten getrackt werden
dort hat sich dann allerdings offenbart
dass grundsätzlich 50 prozent an den
handel gehen das ist eine wichtige sache
dass der buchhandel weiter bestehen
bleibt aber 50 prozent weil sie jetzt
nicht wie diese zahl zustande kommt wenn
wir also ein buch für 15 euro verkaufen
gehen grundsätzlich 7 euro 50 an den
buchhandel
wie kommen wir in den buchhandel dafür
gibt's buch zwischenhändler großhändler
habe mich probiert mit dem in verbindung
zu setzen
super und convenience lösungen da sein
buch irgendwie rein zu bekommen und
gefühlt so ein bisschen den großen
verlagen vor vorbehalten
was absolut absoluter träsch ist
wirklich komplett scheiße hab da ein
bisschen angefangen zu recherchieren und
als erstes mal geschaut wer für den
bestseller listen verantwortlich ist
damals die gfk heute die media control
gibt es eine möglichkeit die eigenen
shops mit in die bestseller
bestsellerlisten rankings aufzunehmen
also die daten quasi haben sie zu
übermitteln
[Musik]
ok to go wird weil natürlich werden auch
bücher außerhalb des regulären
stationären buchhandels verkauft das hat
mich schon mal wirklich ein bisschen
stutzig gemacht ich habe dann allerdings
herausgefunden dass nicht nur die
verkäufe im stationären handel getrackt
werden sondern auch die über amazon und
wir das vielleicht wisst über amazon
kann jeder seine eigenen produkte
verkaufen kann die selber verschicken
oder die von amazon verschicken lassen
und da wird auch nicht dieser preis von
7 euro 50 an amazon automatisch
angewandt wenn ich aber beispielsweise
ein buch auf amazon in der kategorie
bücherliste wie
amazon die daten automatisch an sie
weitergeben richtig wäre verfälscht weil
wir im stationären buchhandel gar nicht
stattfinden würden das würde
wahrscheinlich bei ihnen dann in der
statistik so aufgeführt als als wäre im
visier auch ist im stationären handel
kein einziges buch verkauft worden und
weil es wäre dort dann das interesse
niedriger richtig also es gibt keine
möglichkeit vorher ihnen die information
zu geben dass wir erst gar nicht in den
stationären handel wollen und dass
deswegen diese daten noch nicht
berücksichtigt werden das geht
wahrscheinlich nicht wichtig gut also da
gibt es auch wahrscheinlich dann keine
andere möglichkeit als sich dann
wirklich mit dem mit dem zwischen
buchhandel zu einigen die das komplett
abwickeln zu lassen
[Musik]
das bedeutet schon mal es gibt keine
möglichkeit dass wir auf die spiegel
bestsellerliste kommen was sehr schade
ist aber kein problem weil amazon ja
selber bestenlisten führt wie kriegen
wir aber unser buch vernünftig in amazon
eingespeist wir bräuchten ja eigentlich
sachen wie isbn nummern also quasi diese
kennung hinten auf dem buch die eure
lehrer euch auch gegeben haben nämlich
genau das richtige physik buch bestellt
habe ich dann die zuständige firma aus
stuttgart gefunden die die isbn nummern
raus gibt und es hat sich herausgestellt
dass man auch automatisch ein verlag
wird wenn man isbn nummern beantragt der
prozess gerade hier diesen verlag zu
gründen ist super aufschlussreiche und
ich finde sehr viele sachen zum beispiel
die vlb mit der die ganzen
buchhandlungen theoretisch auch auf
meinem buch zugreifen können und mein
buch dadurch quasi gelistet wird und die
leute das oder die buchhandlungen dass
auch direkt bei mir bestellen kann
und ich glaube mein verlag steht jetzt
einem großen verlag in nichts nach
natürlich habe ich keine kontakte zu
großen buchhandlungen oder so aber ich
gebe auch eben keine tausende von euros
an leute ab die das buch nicht schreiben
das buch nicht drucken und das buch auch
nicht verkaufen hdb eintragung im hdb
adressbuch mit dem eintrag auf adp
online machen sie die adresse ihres
verlages für buchhändler und leser
findbar und gewährleisten so dass ihr
titel direkt bei ihnen bestellt werden
kann
16 euro das bedeutet ich habe einen
verlag gegründet
ich habe nicht nur irgend einen verlag
gegründet ich habe den verlag verlag
gegründet das bedeutet ich werde das
buch selber verlegen es ist wirklich ein
absolut undurchsichtiges geschäftig kann
komplett verstehen dass es keine neuen
autoren gibt die das machen wollen weil
man damit einfach nichts verdienen kann
man verkauften buch für 15 euro und der
verlag bietet einem einen euro 1 euro 15
dafür an
das bringt überhaupt nichts und ich
finde nicht dass ich das hier mit
unterstützen sollte deswegen werden wir
das buch selber verlegen selber drucken
und das werden wir alles in den
kommenden videos gemeinsam machen jetzt
aber zum wichtigen teil wie könnt ihr
eure geschichte einreichen ist ins buch
schaffen und wie viel verdient daran mit
über den ersten link in der video
betreibung könnt ihr eure kurzgeschichte
in den nächsten sieben tagen einreichen
ich und ein paar andere leute werden
dann alle geschichten durchgehen und die
besten auswählen
wir schauen dass wir möglichst viele
verschiedene stile damit rein bekommt
und ich werde mich eben noch mit
verschiedenen youtube an in verbindung
setzen die noch kein bestseller autor
titel haben dadurch aber einen bekommen
könnten und dann auch eine geschichte
für dieses buch einreichen
ich werde den preis den der verlag mir
angeboten hätte für mich alleine quasi
diese 1 euro 15 verdoppeln und an euch
geben
das bedeutet wir sind irgendwie bei zwei
euro 30 pro buch die zwischen den
autoren also euch aufgeteilt werden und
so könnt ihr daran mitverdienen das
finde ich sehr sehr nice ich bin extrem
heiß und ich hoffe dass diese rechnung
auch wirklich so aufgeht wenn ich mich
verrechnet haben sollte dann muss ich
vielleicht aus eigener tasche da noch
was zu geben ich weiß nämlich noch nicht
genau wie die amazon fies und so weiter
sind
so könnt ihr aber das doppelte von dem
verdienen was eigentlich der verlag
angeboten hat und ich glaube das ist
sehr sehr fair und ihr schreibt eben
kein komplettes buch sondern nur eine
kurzgeschichte ich glaube das wird ein
sehr neues projekt ich bin extrem heiß
und ich bin gespannt wie das buch
gedruckt wird wie wir das verschicken
werden und was da alles noch zu dem
prozess dazu gehört ich kann auf dem
zwei kanal oder so noch mal darauf
eingehen es ist auf jeden fall ein sehr
sehr undurchsichtiges geschäft bei dem
man das gefühl hat dass ein paar große
mächtige gibt die diese gesamte ding
kontrollieren es wird den neuen jungen
autoren auf jeden fall überhaupt nicht
einfach gemacht ein buch veröffentlichen
buch zu schreiben oder wie auch immer
ich hoffe dass ich mit diesem projekt
vielleicht den prozess ein bisschen
offen legen kann und euch noch ein
bisschen mehr zeigen kann worauf es
wirklich ankommt und wie ihr vielleicht
selber ein buch herausbringen könnte das
werden wir gemeinsam machen reicht eine
geschichte unten ein und dann machen wir
das beste buch 20 1 und
20 in eigenregie wir sehen uns nächste
woche macht es gut cous cous cous schau